- [Narrator] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(light, intriguing music)
- Welcome to a Conversation
With History; I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Jan Assmann,
who served as Professor of Egyptology
at Heidelberg University
from 1976 until 2003.
In 2005, he was named
Honorary Professor of Cultural
and Religious Studies at
the University of Constance,
where he continues today.
His most recent book is
From Akhenaten To Moses:
Ancient Egypt and Religious Change.
He is the 2015 Foerster
Lecturer at Berkeley.
Professor Assmann, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Well, by chance, I
was born in Langelsheim,
which is a very small city
in the middle of Germany,
but by chance, and I was raised in Lubeck.
So I spent my youth, during
the war, in Nazi Germany,
and in a medieval city,
Lubeck, at the Baltic Sea,
a city of incredible beauty.
This is a really outstanding city,
or was, because it has been destroyed,
the first German city that was
destroyed in the World War,
in reaction to the destruction
of Coventry by the Germans,
so Lubeck had to pay for
the destruction of Coventry.
But the churches have been rebuilt,
and part of the old town,
and this was the place where I grew up,
where I was raised, and
Lubeck was impressive
and also formative for me as a child,
first because of its atmosphere,
this medieval atmosphere,
an atmosphere which Thomas
Mann, in his novels,
Buddenbrooks, catch so beautifully,
and second, for its music.
Lubeck was and still is a city of music.
Church music.
These churches had wonderful organs
dating from the 15th, 16th, 17th century,
and a group of musicians
that, at that time already,
played on original instruments,
instruments from 17th, 18th century,
and in a tradition that has
only become mainstream in Europe
after 1970, '80, with Nikolaus
Harnoncourt and others;
at that time, they were really pioneers.
So, my mother, who sang
in the church choir
of the (speaking in foreign language),
had close friends in
this circle of musicians
and took me to all their concerts
at the age of three,
four, five, (chuckles)
and for the first two or three years,
of course, I had no sense of this music,
I was utterly bored, sitting
through two or three hours
of Baroque music, but then,
after perhaps two years,
all of a sudden, this
was like a revelation,
the beauty of this music.
- It sounds like you were
born to do classical studies,
to be comfortable in exploring
history and tradition.
- Well, (chuckles) I wouldn't say this.
My parents were architects,
far away from academic scholarship.
My father served as an
architect in the war.
I must say, since I
grew up in Nazi Germany,
I think it's important
to know about, also,
the entanglement of the family,
so I'm happy enough to be able to say
that my parents were strongly opposed
against the Nazi government.
I stayed with my mother
because my father was away
in Finland, and my mother
lived in constant fear
of being denounced for her,
well, (chuckles) dissidence.
So, these first seven years of my life,
this atmosphere of fear and
anxiety, persecution, also,
I think left deep traces.
So, I was raised in a family,
well, of course, of architects.
My mother gave up her
study of architecture
when she met my father,
which was the usual fate
of women at that time.
Also, my family was not
only interested in art
and especially architecture, but also,
they were a typical
specimen of what, in German,
is called (speaking in foreign language).
Bildung, which is a German word,
that cannot be translated,
erudition or not.
Bildung is a very special
German phenomenon,
and it means being acquainted with a canon
of classical writers,
Goethe, Schiller, and so,
also Shakespeare and Cervantes.
So, I grew up among these books,
in the library of my parents,
during a time where there
were no children books.
This was in the war, so
I had to entertain myself
with Schiller and Goethe. (chuckles)
- How old were you during the war?
- Well, I am born in
'38, so during the war,
I was two to seven.
When the war was over, finally, in '45,
I was still seven years old,
but I have a very clear memory
of the enormous, how do you call it,
(speaking in foreign language)
when it were not the
Russians but the British
who came to Lubeck; Lubeck
is just at the border.
This was a competition from East and West:
who will be first?
My mother, of course, lived
in the fear of having to
face the Russian occupation,
but happily enough, it were
the Scots who moved into Lubeck
with their (speaking in foreign language),
their...
- Bagpipes.
Yeah.
- Bagpipes, yeah.
Wonderful.
This was such a relief,
that were the British.
Yeah, I was seven years old
and Lubeck was heavily destroyed,
and the ruins were our playground.
Our main occupation was
to dig in the ruins,
so this was my first encounter
with archeology, (chuckles)
to dig in the ruins for precious things:
tiles from the bathrooms, glazed tiles,
or whatever children will
find and treasure as precious.
- So, how did you make, as
you grew, you were in school,
how did you move toward
the study of Ancient Egypt?
- Yeah (chuckles), well,
I didn't hear anything
about Ancient Egypt in school,
and I was not interested,
so much, in ancient history.
What interested me then was only music,
and I occupied myself in writing music,
and I even went so far
to write an whole opera,
which I started studying
with my fellow pupils,
but was a huge thing, this opera.
It took one year, to
compose it and to study it,
and this year, then, it came too close
to our (speaking in foreign language),
our final exam of high school in Germany,
so the director of our school
forbade any more exercises
of this sort.
- No more opera.
So I gave up composing, also because
with growing, let's say, knowledge,
I became also aware of a
certain lack of talent.
So, when I came to the university,
I started with archeology.
When I was 16, 17,
my parents were friends
of an art historian
who was, during the Nazi time,
director of the Kunsthalle,
the art museum in Mannheim,
and was fired by the Nazis
because he acquired too much
of paintings which they deemed
to be (speaking in foreign language),
modern paintings: French, Impressionist,
but also, of course, Cubism
and all this modern art.
So he was fired by the Nazis
and lived in Heidelberg
as an honorary professor.
He was a great friend of my parents,
and he took a certain care of me,
and initiated me into his world,
which was through a
tradition of Aby Warburg.
Aby Warburg, this art
historian who invented
this special form of (speaking
in foreign language).
German, (speaking in foreign language),
is totally different
from what, in America,
is called cultural studies.
It has nothing to do with culture
as a system of difference,
but it has to do with context,
studying a given object in
all its cultural contexts:
synchronically, who gave the
order, what was the function,
and so on, but also diachronically.
This perhaps laid the foundation
of what I later became
to call cultural memory.
This is also a Warburgian concept.
So, our friend, Gustav Friedrich Hartlaub,
was a representative of
this school of thought
to study art in all its cultural contexts,
not as an isolated phenomenon
but as an expression of culture.
So, this friend,
who acted as a kind of mentor for me,
recommended classical archeology.
So, I started with classical
archeology, but soon,
since I had these ideas of context,
the impression I should study
not only Greek history and art
but everything that was around
on the Mediterranean scene,
so I came across a introductory
course on hieroglyphs
and got hooked immediately.
This was a kind of seduction,
such a fascinating script, hieroglyphs.
- Given your background, the
notion of digging, (chuckles)
in the beginning, digging in these ruins,
but then also coming to
understand the complexity
of a whole political, cultural
system in ancient times,
it seems to be a path that you followed
that came naturally, in a
way, with a lot of hard work.
- Yeah, I didn't follow it consciously,
but in retrospect--
- You fell into it.
(both men laugh)
Yeah.
I like to ask my guests
what skills and temperament
you think go with the
kind of studies you do,
how would you advise students.
How should they prepare for doing the work
of studying classical Egypt,
and what sort of temperament
do they need to have?
- I'm not a typical Egyptologist.
The typical Egyptologist
starts at the age of 10 or 12,
reading introductions to
hieroglyphs under his desk,
being fascinated by a
kind of cryptography,
these hieroglyphs, and so on,
and then turning to Arabic, the Orient,
this kind of Orientalism;
this is a typical way,
and I'm untypical in having
come to Egypt via Greece,
the classical tradition, and also,
being raised in a family
of, in a way, artists,
architecture and so on, without
any scholarly background.
So, what I had to learn,
but perhaps I didn't have it
to learn, perhaps it was already in me,
because also in my family,
I was a kind of stranger
with my music and other interests;
what is important is a
certain love for scholarship,
this kind of rather exotic knowledge,
and without a certain
passion for this kind
of exotic knowledge, it's
useless to study Egyptology.
It's not,
it's not just a profession,
but really, it's both, a
hobby and a profession,
and you never get rid
of it; by day and night,
you are living in this exotic world.
This is also the fascination of it.
It's not our own tradition,
but another tradition.
So, first I would recommend is
learn as many languages as possible
relating to this ancient world,
and to be as fascinated by this kind
of activity as possible.
Also, I think,
one must have a certain interest and
liking of writing.
This kind of study really
is a constant effort
at translating:
translating Egyptian texts,
translating Egyptian culture,
or more generally expressed,
translating a foreign culture
into understandable language.
This explains why I've
written so many books,
but this is important.
This constant effort at
articulating, in your own language
and the language of
your fellow countrymen,
what you are finding.
- Talk a little about the
intellectual community
of Egyptologists; in other
words, how do they learn,
in other words, when
do breakthroughs come,
is it based on archeological finds
or the work of other scholars
in the field, and then,
in addition, it sounds like
you cross many disciplines,
so that makes you unique in a sense
because of this broader
interest in biblical studies,
cultural studies, and so on.
- Yeah.
The special thing about Egyptology
is that it is not divided
in archeology and philology,
whereas Greek studies, and even now, also,
Mesopotamia, Assyriology, is divided
in an archeological
field and a philological.
These two fields do not go together,
they are separate chairs in universities,
whereas in Egyptology, this wouldn't work.
There are inscriptions on every object,
and this, I find rewarding,
that script and language
go together with art and
architecture and so on.
So, the decisive discoveries
or breakthroughs or so,
in my life, were due both to excavation,
finding new texts; at
heart I'm a philologist,
so I live by texts, by
language, and so on,
but these texts have to be discovered,
they have to be excavated.
So, most of the, for me,
really decisive inscriptions
and texts and so, I
discovered in Egyptian tombs,
tomb inscriptions and so on.
But on the other hand, of course, also,
the encounters with important
teachers and colleagues.
I was fortunate enough
to spend a year in Paris
with a teacher, Georges Posener,
who was really a great philologist,
and discoverer and decipherer of texts,
and living with these texts,
and really a passionate
philologist and Egyptologist.
I think it's at Paris where I turned
into a real Egyptologist, only at Paris
at the age of 22, late enough.
So, this combination
of excavation, discovery,
on the spot, on location,
in situ, the text, on the one hand,
normal philological work in the library,
with texts of all sorts
on the other hand; this
combination was very fascinating
and helped me a lot.
The real breakthroughs, well,
this encounter with Posener,
but also, later,
I traveled to Uppsala
to spend two weeks with a
colleague, Torgny Save-Soderbergh,
who had built up, in Uppsala, an archive
of Theban tombs.
Thebes, more than Luxor, the west side,
is a site where five
different cemeteries exist,
starting, as far as date is concerned,
starting in the third millennium BCE
and continued until Roman period.
Hundreds and hundreds of tombs.
Save-Soderbergh collected everything
pertaining to this necropolis:
hand-copies of inscriptions
and photographs and slides,
and I spent two weeks in this archive,
and in this archive, I had begun working
on a dissertation on Egyptian hymns.
Hymns, in this archive,
I discovered hundreds,
hundreds of unpublished inscriptions,
and I'm still...
When I, this morning, will give a lecture
on the evolution of religious
thought in Ancient Egypt,
I'm still living on this
discovery in Uppsala.
This was a real breakthrough.
Then, at that time, one
had very little opportunity
to go to Egypt as a student.
This was very expensive...
Impossible.
So, I had to wait for my doctoral exam
and until I got a travel fellowship.
I then went to Egypt,
went into all these tombs,
which was, at that period, still possible;
now it's not, they are closed,
you have to apply for
the permission to enter
and this is very complicated,
but at that time,
I was given a bunch of keys
and was left alone,
(Harry laughs)
could go in all these tombs,
and made copies of hundreds
of these hymns.
And then I started my own excavation.
- Talk a little bit about
this moment of discovery.
The picture of an archeologist
or an Egyptologist
going into an ancient tomb
appears again and again
in the movies as part of an adventure.
Talk about your emotions
in terms of doing that,
and then some moment of
creative discovery, basically.
Is it like it's shown in the movies?
(both chuckle)
- Well, there are small
tombs, there are big tombs,
and these big tombs, it's really
a maze of rooms, corridors,
staircases and so on, all
covered with inscriptions.
What I did first was just sit
with a lamp of petrol, oil,
and copy these inscriptions,
and everyday I was able
to enter another tomb
to find other inscriptions.
This was really
breathtaking, but also hard,
also hard work, because it's
very hot in these tombs,
and most of them are full of bats.
This is not,
well, there is a certain...
It smells bad, these bats,
but they are also frightening,
if there's a little space and
they fly around and so on,
so it demands a certain
(chuckles) amount of heroism
to do this work.
It's a combination of
fascination and exhaustion.
- Exhaustion?
- Exhaustion, yes, yes, you are exhausted
after a day spent in these tombs.
It's a very special experience,
to enter these tombs
and to find these things.
Then, when we started excavation,
this is another kind of experience.
The normal excavation work
can be extremely boring.
You spend hours and hours
and hours on the site
and nothing happens.
The usual stuff, which comes to light
and which has to be drawn
and photographed and copied,
but all this is routine work and can be...
You start at six o'clock in the morning,
and this goes until two
o'clock in the afternoon,
hours and hours, and
then, all of a sudden,
something really sensational appears,
that's once in 10 years or so. (chuckles)
This is perhaps too pessimistic.
Let's say once in two years.
- So, it sounds like a mixture
of courage and patience,
but also you're coming
there with a background
that allows you to see the
significance of something new.
- [Jan] Yes, yes.
- If you didn't have
that previous hard work
before you get to the, yes.
- Yeah.
I did this excavation...
I told you, I started with a
dissertation on Egyptian hymns,
I made a collection of
these Egyptian hymns,
this means texts of
adoration to a certain deity,
and these texts display
the theology of this deity.
What I very soon discovered was
that there was a kind of development,
that these texts were not
only repeating the same motifs
all over, but there was
a very clear development
leading first to this monotheistic
revolution by Akhenaten,
which was a radicalization
of a certain movement
that went before and continued after it,
and then led to a type of theology
which, this was my thesis,
survived in Greek texts
and was handed down
to the Renaissance and the 18th century.
There was a kind of continuity
by the medium of Greek
philosophers, travelers, intellectuals,
and also, of course, Egyptian
priests who learned Greek
and tried to translate their theology
into Greek language, and
Greek philosophy, also.
They have, also, this certain
mixture of neo-Platonism
and Egyptian theology in these texts.
This was what fascinated me,
and I think I have discovered
this development of thought,
and I discovered it in
these tomb inscriptions.
The great advantage of
tomb inscriptions is
that the texts are dated,
and located, and also, socially located,
so the texts are different
if they appear in the tomb
of a high priest, or officer
in the administration,
a high-ranking officer
or a low-ranking officer,
so this makes
discernible differences:
differences in time, in space,
and also in social structure.
- It sounds like this
hearkens back to your mentor,
who taught you cultural
studies in the German sense,
that in Egyptology, you have the artifacts
that lets you contextualize
what you're finding.
One of the themes in
this collection of essays
is the evolution of ideas in religion,
especially in Egypt.
Talk a little about that,
because you make an important distinction
between how in a theology,
you get an evolution of ideas,
a gradual change, and this
leads to your discussion
of a period in which there was monotheism
in the Egyptian religion.
- I don't believe in a general evolution
in religion, evolution from
polytheism to monotheism,
I don't believe in this general concept,
but I believe in an evolution of ideas,
which has certain
presuppositions, requirements.
So, in order to have
an evolution of ideas,
there must be a discourse,
and a discourse requires
that the statements are
preserved in writing
and accessible to later generations
that can build on these earlier statements
and develop the ideas, and also
reject them, react to them.
These are the conditions,
also: writing, accessibility,
and also, a kind of professionalization.
All these conditions were
given in Egypt at that time.
There was professional class
of literate people, priests
and scribes, at the administration,
these high- and middle-ranking officials,
a class of literate professionals,
who were keenly interested
in ideas about the divine,
and who not only had hymns
inscribed in their tombs,
but obviously,
who took an individual
part in the composition
of these hymns, because these
hymns were fairly individual.
So, we have all the conditions
for a discourse to develop,
and I think this explains
this evolution of ideas
between 1500 and 1100 BCE.
It does not continue, and
also, what went before
was very repetitive, but
during these 400 years,
there was a real development.
This development or evolution of ideas
reacted to certain historical experiences,
and I think the most
decisive experience was
the breakdown of their
traditional image of the world,
Egypt coextensive with creation,
the ordered world surrounded by chaos.
This was the traditional image.
In the middle of the second millennium,
Egypt was ruled by foreign invaders,
the so-called Hyksos, who brought to Egypt
new techniques of warfare,
and were subsequently expelled
by a kind of liberation war.
Then, Egypt, by expelling these Hyksos,
inherited their kingdom,
so, their Asiatic, Middle-Eastern realm.
So, Egypt expanded, to
the south, to the north,
became an empire, and came into
contact with other empires:
the Hittites, the Babylonians,
Mitanni, which was then Assyria,
and entered in, also, in
diplomatic relationships,
correspondences, and so on.
So, they learned that the
ordered world did not end
with the Egyptian borders,
and this led to a kind
of universalist thinking.
So, the idea that the
Creator was responsible
not only for Egypt but
also for these countries,
which meant, also, that
the sun, the sun god,
became more and more important,
because the sun was the visible symbol
of universal activity, rulership.
So, the traditional polytheistic image
became more and more
challenged, and the
position of the sun god
became more and more
important, until Akhenaten
introduced a radicalization of this image,
abolished all the other gods
in favor of the sun god,
which, for him, was not
the traditional sun god;
the traditional sun god was,
(chuckles) well, not only the sun,
the sun was the visible symbol
of a deity that was hidden behind,
but for Akhenaten, it was
the sun and only the sun.
- This was a ruler of
Egypt, in about 13...
- 1350s, I think, '60s,
'50s, '40s, and so on.
So, this was a monotheism,
but perhaps, rather, a
monism, because the sun
was just the sun; it was
not a personal deity.
For the king, it was, so there
was a personal relationship
between the sun, the
father, the king, the sun,
but not for human beings,
they were on the same plane
as the animals, the plants, and so on,
living by the light, and also by the time.
The sun not only emits light,
but also time, by its motion.
This was the idea of Akhenaten,
that the whole reality can be explained
as the activity of the sun,
so the other gods are unnecessary,
they are just fictions.
- In your work, you make a
comparison and a distinction
between Akhenaten and Moses.
In other words, there are
some striking similarities,
but striking differences.
- There's one similarity, which is
the abolition of other gods,
and I think this is a very bold step,
to negate the existence of gods.
Akhenaten was the first
one to take this step,
to just negate the
existence of other gods,
with whom Egyptians had lived
for more than 2,000 years.
This was a very bold step.
Then, we meet the same
negation of the existence
of other gods, the exclusion
of the worship of other gods.
We meet, of course, in the Bible.
This is the
one point of similarity,
but there are other
points of huge difference
that exclude the possibility
of any historical influence.
There is none.
There is no causal
influence of Akhenaten...
- [Harry] On Moses.
- On Moses, not at all.
Because the Moses project
is just the opposite.
It's not about cosmology, about the sun.
Moses's question, and Moses, of course,
is a symbolic figure, is
not a historical figure,
so Moses's question is not
how reality comes about
and what energies are active in the world,
but his question was the covenant,
this covenant between a god and a people,
a god acting not as a cosmic energy
but in history, as a ruler, as a partner,
a partner in a political
treaty and alliance.
So, totally different idea,
that God is our ally, our ruler.
It is about the genesis
of a people, of a nation,
the Israelite nation,
and not about the world.
This is not God the Creator,
this is the Book of Genesis,
this is not Yahweh, this is Elohim,
but the idea of Yahweh
as a leader of a people
whom he liberates from Egyptian slavery,
so this is a political
idea, a social idea,
an idea of social identity,
and nothing of this
has anything to do with Amarna,
with Akhenaten, and so on.
Akhenaten's is a cosmology,
and here, this is more
religion in the sense we
understand this word: a covenant.
But still, there is this element
of iconoclasm, and one could
go further and say theoclasm,
of the destruction a divine world.
In later times, thousands years later,
in retrospect, in memory, Moses
and Akhenaten came together,
in Egyptian memory.
There was a kind of distorted
memory of Akhenaten.
Akhenaten, of course, after his death,
fell victim to a damnatio memoriae,
all the traces of his existence
were destroyed, erased,
his name erased from the king lists,
so there was no memory of
the existence of Akhenaten,
but of course, there was
the traumatic experience
of his destruction of religion.
A vague memory of this
trauma stayed on in Egyptian,
and reappeared in Greek
texts of a much later period,
and in one of these Greek texts,
Akhenaten and Moses come together,
because this text by Manetho,
it doesn't speak of Akhenaten
because this name was
erased from the king lists,
but it's quite evident
that this certain Osarsiph
of whom this text speaks
is no other than Akhenaten.
His deeds correspond exactly
and the time correspond
exactly to the Amarna period,
and this text says that after having
given laws to his followers,
he assumed the name of Moses.
So, in the Late Period,
the traumatic memory
of this monotheistic episode in Egypt
was brought into relation
with what they then learned
about the biblical monotheism.
- Which raises an important
area which you've worked on,
which is this whole
idea of the canonization
of a religious text
as key to the survival
of a religion over time.
There's almost an evolution of ideas,
where a text is written,
writing is very important,
that text is made holy, but
to the side is a body of work
that examines that holy text, an exegesis,
and what you're suggesting is
this development of religion
is key to remembrance, to cultural memory,
which is key to the resilience
and survival of a religion.
- Yes, yes.
Yeah, this is a process which
did not take place in Egypt,
but in Israel.
In Egypt also, as fast
as Alexander is concerned
and the Greek tradition,
but which also took place
in India and China, and
very much at the same time.
This means that a certain body of text,
was canonized, so, declared,
well, unchangeable,
and that every further
change must take the form
of commentary, and I
think the introduction
of commentary, this is the decisive step.
Not only, of course,
there were texts around
for thousands of years, but the step
of canonizing these texts, of prohibiting
any further alteration
so the words must stay,
and then that every other,
let's say, development
must take the form of
commentary, this decisive step
occurred twice, in the Eastern
Mediterranean and in India,
at the fourth, third, second century BCE.
The rise of commentary.
We see that
this corpus of biblical
text became canonized--
- For example, in Judaism, the Torah.
- Yeah.
Yes.
The Torah--
- But then a Talmud and
Midrash, which comments on.
- These are the comments
which, until then,
the comments were written into the text.
So, the biblical texts
show the traces of growth
over centuries, with glosses inserted
and also the combination
of different sources,
documents, and so on, and
all this has come to an end
at the third, second century BCE,
so the text was fixed
and this gave rise to commentaries.
The same in Alexandria,
in obvious relations, because
Alexandria was also the place
of a strong Jewish community,
so they knew in Alexandria
what was going on in Palestine,
and in Alexandria, the
Library of Alexandria,
where all literature of the
ancient world was collected,
in order to master
this huge mass of books,
the people in charge
introduced a distinction
between the books to be treated
and the books to be excluded.
So, collected but in an
archive, but not treated.
(speaking in foreign language),
the books to be treated,
and treatment means commentary.
So, in Alexandria,
there was created the canon
of classical Greek literature,
and very much at the same time,
in India, the Pali canon
of the Buddhist writings.
Buddhism then went to
China and then gave rise
to huge, huge bodies of commentary:
Buddhist commentary, Taoist commentary,
Confucianist commentaries.
I think it was these commentaries
that brought about a change
of mentality and thought, which, later,
Karl Jaspers called the Axial Age.
Karl Jaspers was not
interested in the media
of transmission, but only in the ideas.
But it was not a question of ideas,
it was really a question of media,
of writing and canonization
and exegesis and so on,
that brought about a
new form of continuity
that later times were able
to relate to the past.
A new form of relating to the past;
also, to a past given a
new kind of normativity,
that the past was believed to
be the classical foundation
of every changing present,
so that the philosopher
Whitehead could call
all Western philosophy
as just a collection
of footnotes to Plato.
So, this relation to the classics,
and as a relation to the past, as an
opening of the future,
we can go further because
we see what went before.
These ideas of intellectual progress
and of modernity and so on requires
access to the past
in order to go on in the same direction.
So, in a way, writing is crucial,
the canonization of writing and
the exegesis of the writing,
so in a way,
your work as an Egyptologist
is informed by your knowledge
and work as a student
of comparative religion,
because Egypt shows
you what didn't happen,
but in the case of the
Jews, which you focus on
in your essay, the story of
Exodus, the story of Moses,
even the ritual play of the Seder,
which celebrates Exodus,
in addition to the book,
in that way, you come to understand
what allows a religion to
survive to modern times.
- This transition, from what
I call ritual continuity,
which was the case of Egypt,
Egypt was a civilization
of incredible stability,
starting in 3,000 Before Christ
and ending somewhere 300
AD in the Roman Empire,
and this stability was based on rituals,
rituals that implied great bodies of text.
There were no ritual actions
that were not accompanied
by recitation, so these
Egyptian rituals were
also a very verbal activity, recitation.
But,
the backbone of continuity
was ritual action,
and this was due to, I think,
all these ancient civilizations,
all these relations to religions
of the ancient world, except Israel.
Israel, that was forced
by the Babylonian exile
to live on without temple, without ritual,
without state and kingdom and so on,
and who went into the Babylonian exile
with, already, the emergent
canon of the Torah.
Then, due to Babylonian exile,
they elaborated this emergent canon
and by doing so, invented an
alternative type of continuity:
textual, text-based.
So, the recitation, the
reading, the exegesis of text
as a substitute for ritual continuity,
and when they came back to Jerusalem
and rebuilt the temple,
the Torah became the kernel
of the emergent Bible
with the three parts of Torah
and prophets and writings,
and eventually exegesis, but this started
in the Babylonian exile, and was forced
by exterior historical
circumstances, by catastrophe,
by destruction of every
other basis of continuity,
and then became, of course,
the model for Christianity,
and Islam, and other religions.
- Regrettably, our time is up,
but you really have helped
us in this discussion
and conversation to
understand what we can learn
from a religion in the ancient past
that is no longer living, but also,
how the adaptation over
time of other religions
allowed them to survive in the present,
so it's really about comparative religion,
as a sideline, so to speak, in your work.
- Yeah.
(chuckles) Well, of course,
being a Christian and having, of course,
been grown up with biblical
texts, not so much in my family
but the school and so on,
I studied Egyptian texts with
a kind of implicit comparison,
and found, during, say, the first 20 years
of my Egyptological activity,
I was struck by the parallels.
In Egypt, the same kinds of texts,
so many parallels to the Bible.
Only afterwards I became aware
of the categorical differences
and of the revolutionary
newness of the biblical texts,
so this was, again, comparison,
but in a different key.
First, the similarities,
and then, the differences.
- Well, on that note, I want to thank you,
Professor Assmann, for taking
the time to be with us,
and this really fascinating
discussion of your work.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation With History.
(light, intriguing music)